decenas de muertos centenares de
desplazados miles de viviendas de
automóviles destruidos sólo el martes
llovió en petrópolis más que toda la
media prevista para febrero así se
produjeron más de dos centenares de
corrimientos de tierra que lo tragaron
todo
alrededor de ocho familiares estaban en
casa perdí a mi sobrino ya su hija de
cinco años todavía no los han encontrado
no esperábamos esta tragedia es el fin
de nuestra ciudad
con la declaración del estado de
catástrofe de los equipos de emergencia
tratan de buscar a los desaparecidos
mientras los desplazados buscan techos
improvisados como esta iglesia donde
encuentran consuelo no dejes pescadero
que muchas personas lo han perdido
absolutamente todo no les queda nada
solo hay que darles la bienvenida
proporcionarles un techo atención y un
abrazo en este momento tan importante en
ese momento es muy importante
ubicada a 70 kilómetros de río de
janeiro petrópolis es conocida como la
ciudad imperial y aunque montañosa
turística y de casas señoriales su
población ha ido creciendo por las
laderas en áreas vulnerables por la
deforestación y un mal drenaje
por lo que estos eventos han sido
habituales en las últimas décadas en
2011 900 personas murieron en petrópolis
y otros municipios de alrededor a causa
de otro deslizamiento
muertes que los expertos aseguran que
aumentarán con el cambio climático por
el momento este 2022 ha empezado con
sucesos similares en el estado de minas
y en el estado de sao paulo que ya han
dejado más de 40 fallecidos